all right great to be back and start
another week not really but but sort of
I hope you all had a great wonderful
weekend I'm I'm not sure if you noticed
but the women's March happened this
weekend and the hilarious thing is that
nobody seems to have noticed and no one
seems to care which is unfortunate
really when you think about it because I
don't mean to make light of it but you
think of all those cats that were left
alone for the day and I'd hate to think
that they were left alone for no reason
at all attendance for the women's March
has been of course plummeting every year
since the first year in 2016 and there
was a big deal made of the the huge
turnout in 2016 well 2017 it was lower
2018 even lower 2019 last year there
were I think the estimates I solved but
700 thousand people showed up but that
is including all of the 650 local
protests that happened across the
country add all of that together 650
plus the big one in DC you get to around
700,000 pretty poultry turnout when you
consider the number of protests that
were being held now it's interesting I
think to compare this to the March for
Life the women's March couldn't which
the March for Life which by the way
happens this coming Friday women's March
couldn't sustain itself for even three
years the March for life on the other
hands been going strong for 40 years and
consistently pulls you know half a
million people at just one March it just
at just just into DC okay not at 600
different locations the difference I
think you know why is it that the March
for Life can sustain for sick for 40
years or more while the women's March
essentially lasted one year and has just
been dying a slow death ever since I
think there's a few differences first of
all the March for Life has a clearly
defined purpose and goal whereas the
women's March well nobody could ever
really figure out what exactly these
people wanted or what they're so upset
about we know they don't like Trump okay
we get that but is there anything else
is there any actual injustice that
they're trying to fight against and then
the other thing is that the March for
Life is full of young vibrant energetic
positive people and if you go to the
March for Life that's that's the first
thing if you
it's the first thing that jumps out of
people when they go is number one
everybody's so young here number two
everyone so happy you know they're
determined they're you know there's
there's there is a certain righteous
anger at the injustice of abortion but
there's also an optimism and positivity
there as opposed to the women's March
which is full of well this Trump Mike
Pence white supremacy racism misogyny
homophobia that's you know an angry
bitter fifty year old woman in neon hair
shouting obscenities into the void is
really the perfect encapsulation of
modern feminism in 20 in the year 2020
that's that's what the feminism is we're
right there what you just saw that's it
that's all feminism's got and it's also
the perfect encapsulation of why nobody
wants anything to do with these people
and why no normal person would want to
show up at a March with them and that I
think brings us to the biggest
difference between the March for life
and not just the women's March but most
other political rallies that you see the
big difference is that the people at the
March for life are there to defend the
rights of other people okay nobody is
there for a selfish reason nobody is
there demanding something for themselves
there's not anything wrong in principle
with with you know rallying or marching
to defend your own rights nothing wrong
with that but I think it's it always
seems profound to me and pretty
beautiful that at the March for Life
that's not what people are doing they're
not defending their own rights they're
defending the rights of other people
everyone is there to speak for and on
the behalf of humans who cannot speak
for themselves it is then a
fundamentally selfless event and it's
precisely I think what motivates and
attracts people to it ironically or
maybe counter-intuitively
the
fact that you're not going for yourself
is exactly why people want to go okay
much else to discuss today but first a
word from zip recruiter you know it's so
important if you're a business obviously
to hire the right people but these days
probably like it's always been but
especially I think these days it can be
really difficult and every employer
knows this whether you're a big company
or small company or anything in between
you know how difficult it can be to find
the right people and that's where zip
recruiter comes in zip recruiter sends
your job to over a hundred of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technologies that procured or scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply for your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five of
employees who post on zip recorder
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day I
think that the the success rate there is
so enormous that I just have to
reiterate that four out of five
employers who post on zip record recruit
or get a quality candidate through the
site within the first day and right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash Walsh that zip
recruiter comm slash Walsh Wal SH zip
recruiter comm slash Walsh zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire now okay so I
really want to begin today with I guess
too late to begin I've already started
but I want to talk about a story that
went viral last week but that's already
been abandoned by the media certainly
and by most people we've moved on to
other things and this is the game that
the media loves to play they send a
story massively viral get everybody
talking about it or talking about rather
one version of it and plant that version
into people's heads and then move on
move on quickly and especially move on
quickly once the real facts start coming
out then you're then you're it's it's
not know you're dropping that to the
side and and and saying oh look over
here there's something else to talk
about here's another point to another
shiny object for people to focus on so
that the impression of the story you
gave them stays in their heads at the
back of their mind while they move on to
something else and usually I think
people in my position let the media get
away with this game following their lead
about what to talk about because we
don't want to be seen as discussing
yesterday's news or being irrelevant
fortunately though I don't especially
care about being relevant irrelevance he
doesn't bother me that much
so I want to go back to ancient history
of five days ago and discuss this you
may you may remember seeing this story
online about a girl who was supposedly
expelled from a Christian school simply
for having a rainbow cake on her
birthday that was the narrative
narrative is very simple evil Christian
school expels innocent student for
something as silly as a rainbow cake
evil Christian school is so paranoid and
so homophobic that even something as
innocuous as a rainbow decoration on a
cake
sends them into a tizzy that was the
story now to refresh your memory here
are some of the headlines from the mass
media about the story NBC Christian
school expels teen after rainbow sweater
and cake were deemed lifestyle
violations huffington post Kentucky teen
expelled from school for rainbow shirt
and cake mom says The Today Show
Christian school expels teen after she
poses with rainbow
birthday cake Washington Post Christian
school expels teen after she posed with
rainbow birthday cake mother says CBS
Christian school expels teen for rainbow
sweater and birthday cake that violate
quote Christian values so you get the
idea some of these headlines at least
put on the little addendum of mother
says or according to mother some of them
don't even put that on there they just
they just report it as fact CBS just
reports as fact this kid was expelled
for this reason now let me actually take
one of these articles the CBS one and
I'll read to you how they frame the
story in the article it says a teenager
from Kentucky celebrated her 15th
birthday last month by blowing out the
candles on a rainbow cake while wearing
a rainbow sweater after her mother
posted a photo from her birthday party
on Facebook the teen was expelled from
her Christian high school Kayla Kenny
was a freshman at Whitefield Academy a
private Christian school in Louisville
until she was expelled last week her
mother said the school called her
daughter's sweater and cake lifestyle
violations Kennedy Kenny's mom Kimberly
Alford told the Louisville
courier-journal that she receives an
email from Whitefield Academy as head of
school Bruce Jacobsen expelling her
daughter he wrote that the picture she
posted on Facebook demonstrates a
posture of morality and cultural
acceptance contrary to that of
Whitefield Academy's beliefs while the
rainbow flag is a symbol of LGBTQ rights
alfred said that when she ordered the
cake the design was described as having
assorted colors and was not meant to
have a deeper meaning Wow pretty
horrible right I mean it seems horrible
if you're frankly stupid enough to still
take these kinds of stories at face
value which unfortunately lots of people
are it seems but there is no excuse to
be that stupid anymore there is no
excuse to be so gullible as to hear some
kind of outrageous accounting of an
event from the media and assume that it
must be exactly as the media portrays it
and that's in fact what I said last week
when somebody emailed the show and asked
me how why
think about this story and you know
what's my take on it
I said well based on the the version the
media is giving us sounds like this girl
suffered a horrible injustice but I'm
not gonna simply believe that version
yes that version says that the school
did a horrible thing but that version
I'm not going to believe because there's
almost certainly another side to the
story and sure enough there is another
side to it and we'll talk about that
other side in just a minute but first a
word from Rock Auto you know I've I've
recently been having a lot of problems
with with both of our cars as it turns
out because usually that's that's our
experience is that when one car goes
down the other the other follows it's
just it's just a it's a rule of the
universe and one of the problems is you
know when you're having trouble with
your car and you go to an auto parts
store and you're looking for the parts
that you need they're gonna give you the
runaround and a lot of times they're
gonna end up just going online and
ordering for you the part that you need
because they never have it in stock
that's why you need rockauto.com if you
need to work on your car and you need a
part don't waste your time and go to an
auto parts store store go to Rock Auto
calm rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years ago to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil new carpet
everything you need whether it's a
classic or a daily driver get everything
you need and a few easy clicks the
rockauto.com catalog is super easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and filter by
brands well you filter by brand you can
filter by ease specification by price
whatever you need it's it's very easy to
navigate that way best of all the prices
at rockauto.com
are always reliably low and they're the
same no matter who you are if you're a
professional if you're do it yourself or
doesn't matter amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now and see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
now the other side of the rainbow cake
story which by the way you know why have
cakes become the most controversial
pastry in America III remember a time
when cakes were just cakes you know you
you just have a cake but now it's every
six months there's an outrage centered
around a cake which i think is very
upsetting right I want to go back to a
time when when when you know you just a
cake is just a nice delicious dessert
that you eat but in any case Raj rare in
the American Conservative has a
fascinating piece posted on the website
right now titled rainbow cake girl the
true story you could go read the piece
and he gives the other side he talked to
some of the people at the school he also
looked at the social media postings of
the girl in question and read the public
statements from the school on this
matter and he presents a different
picture now I'm not gonna go through and
reiterate all of it you can go read the
piece yourself to suffice to say first
of all that she was not expelled simply
for a cake the cake thing was the last
straw
in a long line of infractions including
some that her mom even admits to like
vaping in school for example but there
were many other issues according to the
school and other parents at the school
so to report that she was expelled for
the cake is inaccurate it's a lie if
somebody commits a series of infractions
and the sum total of which gets them
expelled and then you come along and and
say that the the last infraction in the
series is the thing that got them
expelled on its own then that's that's
just not true that's dishonest
second point according to Jerry Speas
the cake was was not just a random cake
allegedly one of the main bones of
contention that the school had with this
girl is that she at the school and on
social media had constantly been
promoting the LGBT lifestyle this is a
Christian school that believes in in the
biblical teaching on homosexuality and
everyone who goes to the school agrees
in writing you know by by siding on
to the rules of the school agrees to
affirm that biblical teaching or at
least to not publicly contradict it now
if you disagree with the school's view
on homosexuality that's fine you don't
have to agree just you're free to go to
any other school just don't go to that
school it's really simple this is what
every time you get one of these
controversies with someone's expelled
from school because of some LGBTQ thing
just don't go to that school you there
are so many other schools and this is a
private school so that you have to pay
for you could go to public school if you
want or find a different private school
trust me there are a lot of Christian
schools out there who don't care at all
about their Christian identity and
they'll throw open the doors for you or
you can homeschool I mean there are so
many options if you choose to go to this
particular school you are signing on to
those rules so allegedly this family
agreed sign on the dotted line then
proceeded to disregard the agreement
they made as this girl allegedly went
around promoting LGBT stuff at school
and online and then after all this back
and forth of the school and the schools
repeated warnings she posts a picture of
with the rainbow cake and the rainbow
sweater and we're supposed to believe
that the rainbow aesthetic in this case
was totally arbitrary and random and not
at all meant you know just to symbolize
anything come on now of course if the
media had reported this story honestly
which and and just said that a student
was expelled from a Christian school for
promoting the LGBT lifestyle which which
actually would not even be fully honest
because there's more to the story even
than that but that's at least more
honest if they had done that that still
would be considered a controversial and
bigoted move by a lot of people so the
media could have still ginned up outrage
and contempt towards this school which
is really what they were trying to do
what this was all
about could have done that by being
mostly honest in other words the real
story in a lot of people's minds these
days isn't much better than the fake
story that the media originally gave us
which you know fine be that as it may
the truth matters and the right of a
private school to have a certain
identity matters and the responsibility
of students and parents to abide by the
rules they agreed to upon entering the
school matters you don't have to agree
with the school's moral position on
homosexuality but you should be able to
see that students and families don't
have the right to enter into a private
school and then openly flout blatantly
disregard the rules and policies they
expressly promised they would follow and
that's what's happening here now
one other thing I want to say about this
you know personally I'm always
uncomfortable talking about stories like
this you know I don't want to be
publicly discussing a 15 year old girls
sexuality or her views on them on
sexuality or anything like that or her
problems at school or the fact that she
was expelled I think all that is is is
her business it's with her between her
and the parent and school and I'm not in
the business of publicly shaming
children who make mistakes but this is
the situation that the media and the and
the parents create okay it's the parents
who decided to bring this issue to the
media and to air their grievances
against their school to the national
media to publicize their daughter's
situation and it's the media who blasted
this story all over the place and then
you know the rest of us who would rather
not talk about it are left with a
decision are we going to ignore it and
let a false narrative metastasize and
even at the expense of the school and
its administrators who are being
unjustly smeared are we going to do that
or are we gonna speak up for truth and
for fairness if the latter which is what
I favor then were forced to discuss
aspects of a kid's private life which
again is entirely on the parents and the
media for creating this situation
because really you know we're so used to
this these days this kind of thing that
I think we don't even we don't even give
it a second thought anymore but you know
there's no reason taking all the LGBT
stuff out of it I mean whatever the girl
gets expelled from her school there's no
reason why that is national news no
reason no reason why NBC and CBS need to
be covering it no reason why thousands
hundreds of thousands of not millions of
people online need to be chiming in it's
not Nash
News it has no national relevance this
is something that happened in Louisville
Kentucky and if you don't go to that
school and you're not in that community
it has no relevance to you doesn't
affect you you you have no insight into
the situation because it is it's it's
it's a it is a controversy between
individuals in a particular place so you
don't know anything about the situation
you can't know anything about it you
couldn't possibly have anything
worthwhile to add and so that's why this
shouldn't be national isn't that and
that's why in the past prior to the
internet we would never hear about
something like this if you were in the
community you'd probably catch wind of
it but certainly if you went to the
school you would you would know about it
but then that's okay because you're
close to it you're close to it so it
does affect you in some way it's
certainly something that you're around
and you might actually have some insight
into it because you know the people
concerned and you know all that kind of
stuff but if you were you know if this
happened in Louisville Kentucky and you
were living in Jersey City you just
never hear about it and you would go
about living your life
but now these personal issues these
small localized personal issues become
national news and everyone butts in and
and it just nothing good can come of it
and that's why it frustrates mean it
makes me angry especially to see parents
encouraging this even if you think that
your kid is in the right even if you
think your kid is a perfect little angel
why would you want why would you want
millions of people to know about this
see if it were me and and my kid were
expelled from school I'm certainly not
I'm not gonna put it online I'm
certainly not gonna publicize it myself
and if the media comes to me for some
reason and asks me about it I'm gonna
have no comment I'm gonna say leave us
alone this is you know what do you this
says nothing doesn't concern you CBS
alright let's let's read some emails by
the way well put well while I pull up
these emails I want to mention i watch
the force awakens with my kids on
Saturday first time I've seen it I think
it's maybe a known fact about me at this
point that I'm not a big star Wars fan
but my sons are major into Star Wars now
I don't know how it happened I tried to
shield them from the fate of becoming a
Star Wars fan but it did I against my
wishes they become obsessed with Star
Wars it's like something it's like
almost something evolutionary something
clicked in their minds and all of a
sudden they're running around the house
with lightsabers and which side note to
the side note on Friday my my son says
to me he says daddy I want to be I want
to be a Jedi when I grow up and I said
oh you know me too I might not be a big
Star Wars for him but I I'd love to be a
Jedi and he said but you're already
grown up and you're not a Jedi then I
said yeah yeah that's true daddy you
yes I did in so many ways in so many
ways kids always know how to lift her
spirits like that but anyway so I
watched the movie and I'm I'm you know
I'm at the age of 33 now and I'm just
now getting acquainted with Star Wars
universe so I have only two questions I
want to throw out there and maybe you
can email your answers to me because I
really am curious first of all and this
was bugging me the whole time I'm
watching a movie our people drawn to the
dark side because they want to wear the
cool helmets and masks I've noticed a
real deficiency with the good guys when
it comes to cool helmets and masks why
is it that only the bad guys wear them
it seems like anyone could wear the and
they wear them when they don't need to
you've got like stormtroopers walking
around the ship you know on friendly
territory and there's apparently the the
ship's oxygenated so they could take the
helmet off but they're you know they're
in the break room
having some coffee and they got the
helmet still on so but and I get it
because it looks cool it's just it's a
cool look and I'm my thing as the good
guys they could probably I mean the kylo
you know kylo Ren right isn't the whole
reason he went to the dark side is
honestly just that he wanted to wear a
cool helmet and he wanted to look like
Darth Vader that's the whole reason
there's only reason he became a bad guy
is because he wants to wear the cool
costume so you could I think the good
guys could really stop that from
happening and kind of stop the bleeding
as it were losing all these Jedi's to
the dark side if if someone just ran to
Party City and grabbed some costumes and
then they could say to somebody like
kylo Ren no no look we've got costumes
too you know you want your own costume
you want to design something that's fine
we've got people that can make costumes
and then my second question and this
this really this bugs me the most and
this honestly might be one of the main
reasons I never got into Star Wars what
I don't understand is this it's your
you're in a galaxy with extraordinarily
advanced technology we're talking so
advanced that that just your average
commuter
chips can go the speed of light the
millennium falcon is is in a junkyard
and it can go the speed of light or go
faster this be not only that but is it
Han Solo crashes the ship in the force
awakens crashes it while going the speed
of light and no one even gets a bruise
so these are ships that are can not only
go that fast but are made of some kind
of material that is literally
indestructible that's the kind of
technology you have on top of that you
got robots that have that can pass the
Turing test they're conscious c-3po
appears to be conscious right he has
thoughts and feelings okay really
advanced technology and yet you're using
swords me a lightsabers a glorified
sword it's a laser sword all of this
technology and you're using a sword to
fight people you're telling me you
couldn't come up with a weapon that
would make that sword irrelevant and if
a guy comes at you with a laser sword
you could just shoot him right and
that'd be the end of it now I know
you're gonna say oh well they could
block the you will you see in the movie
they block the lasers with their sword
yes because the laser guns the lasers
that come out of the lasers and the
laser guns are super slow you see off
slow those lasers are they they go at
the speed of a nerf of a nerf bullet at
most they go the speed of a fast ball of
maybe a minor league fastball and that's
why they're so easy to block and
everyone gets on the stormtroopers case
when they say and I've heard this before
about how that's you know the the joke
is the stormtroopers can't hit anybody
and they got the worst aim in the galaxy
but the reason is that the lasers are
going so slow so they're easy to dodge
so why not make a gun with a laser that
goes the speed of an actual laser and in
lieu of that just get a regular gun like
a sawed-off shotgun and you could kill
every Jedi in the galaxy no problem so
that's my thing I I just I don't it
would be like if I made a story about a
future world with super advanced
technology where you know everybody in
their home has a 4d 50-feet TV screen
that's about the you know is about the
width of a postage
stamp and and all you know Holograms and
virtual reality yet we're still using
VHS tapes it just doesn't make any sense
and it bothers me alright let's go to
emails this is from Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Jonathan's as future
supreme overlord Walsh I was listening
to your podcast today about forgiving
student loan debt and how it is
conceptually no different than forgiving
any other kind of debt but why does
having debt make someone more deserving
I don't see how a person taking on debt
for things he/she can't immediately
afford and paying it off later makes him
/her
more deserving than a guy who made
decisions to save money up front and
only bought things he could already
afford so he wouldn't have to take on
debt in the first place why wouldn't the
logic for forgiving student loan debt
make literally everything free from the
government
your future subject Jonathan well yeah
Jonathan that's exactly the point
there's no reason it's a favor to give a
special privilege or benefit or
entitlement to people who haven't paid
off their student loan debt and that's
what we were talking about on Friday
there there are there first of all there
a lot of people have debt in this
country most people do most adults do
whether it's car loan debt or credit
card mortgage I mean most people have
all those things and if so if you're
gonna start forgiving debt why not
forgive that or yeah I mean why not well
why not go the other way if you got a if
you got a trillion bucks to to throw
around why not reward people who already
paid off their debts so that's just one
of the problems with the student loan
forgiveness idea this is from Laura says
hello Matt supreme leader of the world I
come to you to have my husband's bacon
judged he says that today it is perfect
but you as the all-knowing will be able
to tell me if it is or not I have
attached a picture for you okay Laura
perfect bacon you say well pride cometh
before the fall but let's see here let's
take a look at it this is the let's take
put the picture up on the screen this is
the supposedly perfect bacon there it is
okay
so I think I get it now your husband
meant that this is the perfect example
of terrible bacon I think that's what he
meant to say I'm gonna assume that's
what he meant to say because that would
make sense in that context yeah okay so
the coloring is okay the actual cook on
the bacon is okay I'm not liking the
color at the top-left corner there you
see that bacon that piece is much darker
than the rest so the incongruity the
lack of symmetry there is very troubling
to me there at the very bottom you've
got that horizontal piece that looks
sickly and looks like it has yellow
fever or something so that's a problem
but all of that you know would only
knock this bacon down to about a c-plus
so if I'm just going based on the cook
and the color I'm gonna say c-plus not
bad also not great the thing that drops
it the rest of the way to an F and
becomes grounds for deportation is the
most obvious thing of all is the mangled
twisted contorted shape of the bacon
itself so what was your husband doing
was he torturing the bacon to get it to
talk I mean it's already dead someone
let him know there's no there's it
doesn't have anything to tell him what
did the bacon do to him that made him
feel like he had to draw and quarter it
yeah when someone puts bacon down in
front of me I expect to see strips of
bacon strips of bacon not mangled clumps
of bacon a perfectly shaped strip neatly
sitting there politely waiting for me to
eat it okay I want to see bacon that is
proud I don't want to see bacon that's
begging me to put it out of its misery
that's my problem
now I I assume that when you saw this
bacon by your husband your immediate
response was to contact a divorce a
divorce attorney and I don't blame you
for that and I'm not saying that it
would be wrong to divorce your husband
for making bacon like this I mean
certainly legally ethically biblically
you you would be well within your rights
but look you got to think about the kids
Laura if you have kids if you don't then
then get out of there as fast you can if
you do you don't want to leave them with
a man who prepares breakfast this way
and so I you know I'm sorry that you're
going through this in your marriage I
and I and the thing is I don't blame
your husband I blame whoever taught him
how to make bacon
that Monstress person and now I fear
that he's gonna pass that down to his
own children and it's like a curse that
will never end let's put a stop to it
all right glad we could have this talk
this is from Trinity says hi Matt random
topic have you ever taken the MBTI
personality test what is your opinion on
this type of test
yes Trinity the myers-briggs personality
test I did take it and I failed
I got enough - on the personality test I
know actually I haven't taken at all I I
have no interest in taking it honestly I
don't understand this obsession people
have with with taking tests to find out
their personality but don't you know
your personality isn't that the one
thing you know most of all in the world
is who I mean you are a better authority
on your personality than anyone else
could be so is it possible that a
multiple-choice tests could provide
better information about your
personality then direct access to your
mind could but this isn't really about
information I realize I don't think
people take these personality tests for
information about themselves I don't
think anyone takes it because they
really want to learn something about
themselves I think they take it for
confirmation they want to have a certain
personality personality trait or a
certain personality generally speaking
and so they take the test to find out if
they do or to find out that they do
because I'm sorry I don't believe I've
seen the questions they ask on these
personality tests I don't believe anyone
takes them honestly I think you kind of
know what personality you're shooting
for and so you're gonna give the answers
that will get you that personality
so it's more if anything it's a test to
find out what kind of person you wish
you were maybe there's some value to
that I don't know but it's it definitely
doesn't tell you who you are it tells
you what you wish you were and that's
why I fight most of the time when
someone takes a personality test and if
I know the person and they tell me what
their result was I'm all an objective
observer I'm always thinking really
that's your personality are you sure
because as someone who has no stake in
the matter and I'm not rooting for them
to have any personality you know any
particular personality trait I can
really see it as wishful thinking
because it's always like yeah you know I
took the test and it told me that I'm an
assertive leader but also thoughtful but
also sociable and intelligent and
mysterious okay so you're James Bond
basically the personality test told you
that you're James Bond what a
coincidence yeah it turns out you're the
coolest person ever you're the most
interesting and and deep and thoughtful
and you know yeah yeah oh what a huge
would Wow good for you my other issue
with personality tests is it may be a
more relevant problem is that I just
reject the whole premise of them I don't
I don't think that a personality can fit
neatly into one of a few standard types
because the the the myers-briggs test
that's the one that has all the like the
INTJ or whatever it right
so there are they've got a stable of of
several personality forms and I guess
the assertion is that everybody fits
into one of those labels and I just
don't agree with that I think that
notion of personality is absurd people
are complicated people change
personalities change personalities also
are not this static thing that stays
with you your whole life
gender is not fluid despite popular
notions but personality is you know
personalities can change quite a bit and
so I just don't agree that finally from
Joey says your argument about not
forgiving student-loan because what
about the people who already paid it
back is stupid so
they not cure cancer because people
already died from it speaking of stupid
Joey first of all the fundamental
unfairness to people who've already paid
back their loans is just one objection
that I have to the student loan quote
forgiveness there are many other
objections that I went into great detail
about but as far as that one objection
goes your analogy is very bad and let me
explain why
first of all cancer is not a thing that
you contractually agree to and enter
into it's something that happens to you
you are a victim of it a student loan on
the other hand is something that you
agree to and enter into you are not a
victim of it it is not something that
just happens to you you don't wake up
one day and you've got you've got
student loan debt you don't go to the
doctor and the doctor says I'm sorry to
tell you I know this is what isn't what
you want to hear but you owe $50,000 to
the University of Maryland it doesn't
work that way I mean you know if because
you went in and not only did you agree
to the student loan but you you eagerly
agreed to it I mean you really sought it
out and wanted it and so you got it
second thing is we don't even have the
theoretical ability to bring somebody
back from the dead right so the idea
that it's unfair to cure cancer now
because it'd be unfair to cancer victims
that have already died would is of
course is ridiculous
but forgiving student loans and
refunding student loans that have
already been paid back both of those
require the same thing which is money
okay we don't it's not like we've
discovered some new cure for student
loans it's just we always knew what the
cure is it's money you just you need
money and if we have trillions of
dollars to throw around somehow then we
have the theoretical ability to do both
and if we're only forgiving loans and
not refunding that's a choice that's
being made and and then we have that
choice has to be justified
if you've got all this money and you're
doing something with loans with it I
mean you could refund the loans it is it
is a theoretically possible thing to do
but it's a we you know according to
Elizabeth Warren and these plans that
are put forth that's not part of the
plan and they should have to explain
that so if you want to compare this to
an illness or a physical injury for some
reason the analogy would have to be
something like there's a disease that
causes people after a while to lose
their limbs and eventually someone
discovers a cure but the cure could also
regrow limbs as well as as stop you from
losing them but then we decide to only
give the cure to people who have not
lost the limbs yet rather than giving
the cure also the people who have lost
it because we figured that well they've
already figured out how to live with you
know fewer limbs and so they don't need
it I guess that would be the analogy but
that is also a dumb analogy it's less
dumb than yours but it's still dumb
because at the other day like I said
this isn't student loans are nothing
like a disease at all it's just not the
same thing and so that's the difference
hopefully I've explained it well enough
you know if you're a regular listener to
the podcast you've almost certainly
heard me talk many times about my
position on the pro-life issue whether
in my podcast my speeches or q and A's
this is something I've spoken about many
many times abortion is not a
reproductive rights issue it's a
parenting issue reproduction has already
occurred by the time the abortion
happens so this is this got nothing to
do with reproduction at all as a matter
of fact but since the passing of roe v
wade over 60 million preborn children
have been killed 60 million children
who've never had a chance to give the
world their love and and and to fulfill
their potential and bring that into the
world as well and also countless young
women have been harmed physically and
emotionally and they've been deprived
the gift of motherhood a gift that they
may not see as a gift when they walk
into the clinic but then of course the
clinic
is there to feed upon and take advantage
of that fear and last year the left one
even further off the cliff passing the
New York law in allowing abortions up to
birth and the Illinois law allowing
abortion up to birth including partial
birth abortion which is the most
barbaric procedure you could possibly
imagine and this year almost every
Democratic candidate supports no
restrictions on abortion and Democrats
in office have even moved to lift
protections on babies who survived
abortion procedures allowing abortion
allowing abortion doctors to kill them
after birth we remember the infamous
statements of Ralph Northam Ralph
Northam talking about you know making a
decision after the baby has already been
born and to make matters even worse than
all that pro-life advocates are actively
being targeted by the pro-abortion left
this past June I spoke at a rally in
Philadelphia after after Brian Simms the
representative there was harassing
pro-lifers peaceful pro-lifers who were
outside of abortion clinics the daily
wire has also been targeted when my boss
ben shapiro spoke at the march for life
last year our advertisers were targeted
by left-wing media watchdogs and several
of them pulled their ads from our
program because he was speaking at the
march for life
this wasn't the first time nor won't
likely be the last time that we are
attacked in an attempt to shut down
pro-life voices we're also not the only
targets of course live action is one of
the biggest voices in pro-life movement
they they continue to do some of the
most important work in that space from
raising awareness and education on the
abortion issue to undercover videos that
expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics for the horrific human
rights abuses that they that they are
responsible for live action has been
targeted numerous times on social media
they've been banned from advertising on
Twitter for their calls to diff'ent to
defund Planned Parenthood they've been
banned from Pinterest altogether for
quote spreading medical misinformation
which is not misinformation at all by
the way but as in fact information is
these are these are facts that they are
spreading they've also seen their
advertising efforts and their online
distribution restricted
depending on on the platform so this has
happened across the board for them but
this cause is too important to stay
silent that is why our daily wired.com
members are so important your membership
keeps our cameras on and our microphones
turned on your direct support helps us
to say no to advertisers who cave to
left-wing ideologies you keep us and our
message from being canceled even though
as you know there are very many people
and organizations out there that would
love to cancel us but you're the ones
who keep that from happening
and that is why from now until January
31st a portion of any daily wire.com
membership will be donated to live
action with promo code live action to
support awareness and education around
the world on this issue so please join
daily wire.com stand with us against
censorship and you can make your
pro-life voice even louder in the
process and I think we'll leave it there
thank somebody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
president Trump's impeachment trial is
about to begin
but the most important story of the day
isn't the Senate charade to acquit the
president our political rot runs all the
way back to the motherland where Queen
Elizabeth is about to D Royal Prince
Harry and Megan Markel we will examine
why with great power comes great
responsibility then the women's March
flops Elizabeth Warren continues her
months long campaign collapse the New
York Times comes out with its
presidential endorsement and we get the
dumbest article on the Internet today
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]